speaking of weather southwest airlines
says weather was a factor in major
travel disruptions across the country
over the weekend the airline canceled
more than 1800 flights starting on
friday that's far more than any other
carrier and it's raising big questions
for southwest arrow barnett is following
this arrow good morning
hey there good morning people are still
feeling the pain right now some
southwest passengers won't make it to
their weekend destinations until tuesday
because of the cancellations and the
ripple effect sources tell cbs news this
is at least partly related to the
airline's announcement it will follow
the federal vaccine mandate which some
southwest pilots disagree with
it's not a great end to a good vacation
long lines snaked around airport
terminals as passengers rushed to rebook
unexpectedly cancelled flights on a busy
holiday weekend we've been on the phone
i think we're on hold for like three and
a half hours now and then we're probably
two hours into waiting in line and
probably another hour until we get there
southwest says air traffic control and
weather related challenges caused
cancellations of nearly 2 000 flights
but the faa responded sunday saying its
staffing shortages ended friday and that
airlines are having challenges due to
aircraft and crews being out of place
industry expert henry hardevelt what
really bothers me is southwest is trying
to blame the faa air traffic control
systems it's like saying the dog ate my
homework
southwest is clashing with its pilots
union over the federal vaccine mandate
swapper filed a lawsuit on friday but
denies it organized a so-called sick out
and says there were many operational
difficulties due to management's poor
planning southwest says it's operating
at lower staff levels than it did
pre-pandemic and cannot recover quickly
still sources tell cbs news a staffing
shortage this weekend was a factor in
why so many southwest flights were cut
what is the connection between the union
lawsuit we saw filed on friday and these
cancellations officially there's no
connection unofficially what i've heard
is there are some rogue pilots who are
anti-vaccine
folks they are not showing up for work
is this disruption a glimpse of what's
to come southwest's absolute meltdown
doesn't bode well for thanksgiving or
for christmas
now internally southwest is apologizing
to some of its staff who could not find
hotel accommodation which only added to
the staffing shortages and cancellations
but consider this the federal vaccine
mandate for airlines hits december 8th
airlines that don't comply could lose
federal contracts while southwest's
pilots union says it is considering a
demonstration for better terms also in
december
yeah let's hope they work that out errol
because you know thanksgiving and
christmas as you point out are coming
thanks a lot